foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I need to see the doctor
one moment please what number were you
calling please
I've got this pain right in mine sorry
the doctor doesn't treat this
[Music]
but about three weeks from Tuesday
the doctor doesn't choose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
insurance
Medicare it hurts about here doc
shine here please
[Music]
x-ray four miles away
EKG that's across town right turning
first left turn and second behind the
develop over the fourth stand you can't
miss it
in order to get all the tests we'll need
I'll want you to check in at the
hospital for a few days
[Music]
a bed
we have a long waiting list how about uh
three weeks from Friday
[Music]
this is ridiculous
[Music]
[Laughter]
a consumer now goes for Health Services
he takes what's offered he can't afford
to shop like he would for a car or
anything else he don't know whether he's
getting Quality Service mediocre service
the poor service he just knows he's
getting what the doctors give it by
having a baby
fifteen hundred dollars that's killing
me I went in there on Monday morning and
came home Saturday when my bill was
723.50 plus my doctor bill was 225.
health care prices are going up at about
twice the rate of the general Consumer
Price Index in this country and that's a
very serious problem it's the fear of a
lingering illness and the way the old
people are treated that's what gets me
well I'm fortunate I don't I have not
had a lot of sickness
now am I
you think we're getting it
I think we've got a long way to go hey
let me out of here out of here
find me another hospital
Jack
you hear anything no
how about that figure of 70 billion
dollars what do we do with that
save it use it later how about adding a
70 bed Wing to this Hospital resources
survey would indicate negative
and extended care facility might be
better one ECF at point x
we really need an area-wide planning
agency here how about it check
how about telling me where I am the
think tank
you're a feedback resource right huh you
probably made a complaint and ended up
in someone's file right wow are you so
don't just stand there do your thing
if the med school at point Y can supply
the physician's assistant we might
consider a nurse coordinator from over
here right work
let's try it
hey with all these hospitals and doctors
and medical schools and stuff how come
the whole setup doesn't work the way it
should well there are a lot of reasons
we don't get the medical care we need we
don't get it when we need it we can't
get the doctors when we need to get to
them oftentimes we can't pay for it when
we get there there is an imbalance
between provision of medical care and
what the medical consumer needs the
consumer has little or no voice the
medical system is not a system well one
of the problems
that accounts for many difficulties that
people personally experience now I think
in obtaining adequate Health Services
is that the present Health Care delivery
system
has grown in a very disorganized a very
fragmented way the patient must find his
way through a maze of services
frequently with no single coordination
point that can help him decide whether
he needs the care of a super Specialist
or the care of a of a nurse for example
or a social worker we are talking about
a system that came into its present
existence its present form without much
careful systematic overall planning in
1966 Congress passed the Comprehensive
Health planning legislation
this law
provides for health planning at the
state level
health planning at the regional or
area-wide level
provides for training of Health planners
if provided for a blocked Grant to
States
which would provide
money to the states which could be put
into any health activity
based on the state's idea of what its
priorities needs were is also the intent
of Congress to provide a mechanism for
hearing the previously unheard the man
in the street the poor the elderly
to give them a voice in the design of
services
that are there to meet their needs
survey studies charts statistics what is
all this stuff research data the
opinions and ideas of experts yeah if
you really want to know what's wrong
with medical care just ask Ordinary
People consumer research ah call it what
you want yes but what do people really
know about health care they know where
it hurts watch we've got Doctors
Hospitals x-ray Labs pharmacies more
doctors Specialists for the head the
bones the nerves the skin the stomach
the eyes the teeth etc etc etc
so what happens when you get sick
[Music]
and so does your wallet
fragmentation of services over
specialization you've got big words for
everything you know what's wrong with
you you just don't know what it's like
out there oh is it so we get sick too
you know
it is one thing to be sick it is quite
another thing to be sick and poor
government-funded Neighborhood Health
Centers such as the Matthew Walker
Center in Nashville Tennessee
and the Park Hill Center in Denver
Colorado are seeking to bring Quality
Health Care within the reach of the
nation's poor whether it's located in a
shopping center or in the heart of a
housing project the idea of a
Neighborhood Health Center is to be
where the people are this is the
Columbia Point housing project in Boston
and this is Ann Stokes a mother of 10
children who still finds time to be
actively involved in the health care
problems of the poor Mrs Stokes is
director of the Columbia Point Health
Association
a community Advisory Group working with
the center a one-time welfare recipient
she knows that the word help takes in a
lot of territory health is a small word
but it covers many areas I can't very
well talk to a boy who's different glue
in the hallway and he tells me he has
nothing to do and I just accept that and
go back home because the only way I can
get them from stuff sniffing glue is to
have something else for him to do I
can't tell senior citizens someone will
take care of you while you go to the
store your handbag won't be snatched I
gotta find though before she's even
beaten up and brought into the health
center I gotta find out where the
policemen are and I mean to me this is
help it's all a part of Health getting
the job done getting the job done at
Columbia Point means providing a wide
range of medical services for more than
a thousand families living in the vast
project
the center occupies three floors of a
converted apartment house
the centers are located in urban and
rural communities where in the past
Comprehensive Health Care was not only
inaccessible but frequently unavailable
in well-appointed and dignified settings
professionalism combines with neighborly
warmth envisions conjured up by what is
traditionally associated with Clinic
care vanish amid spotless cheerful
surroundings
but that part
Family Healthcare teams composed of
internists pediatricians social workers
and Community aides concentrate on the
total context of health problems
in the mental health section men and
women from the community are being
trained as psychiatric aides
a boy with problems in school is being
tested the aid also provides a father
image in Columbia Point there aren't
enough fathers to go around
Columbia Point like every Center has an
advisory Council Community involvement
is the heart of the neighborhood center
concept
it's going to come in common mine to us
uh
will give me the names of these families
right and I swear to God I will not give
him one thing I don't think they could
set up a group thing you know like
alphabetical order I like to have group
one group two and those aides could do
an outreach program on their own by
going to house to house they can knock
on doors and talk to these people see if
they have problems that they don't want
to come in here and talk about an
advisory council is made up of elected
representatives from the community who
are not health professionals but
Community people
they take their jobs seriously
and their Insight is what keeps the
Professionals in touch with the
day-to-day realities involved in
delivering Health Care to the poor I
still say that
they're just wasting their time and my
heart goes out to these mothers how many
points
out wasting their time when you're poor
and you got a lot of kids
there's so many things that are wrong in
your family
that you just don't want to talk to
anybody that doesn't mean that doesn't
mean that you need help with your kids
that means you're frustrated and you're
tired in your own work
we'll never get this thing organized
it's just too big and too complicated
hey why don't we stop complaining about
how bad it is and take a look at some of
the good things that are going on like
what like this Neighborhood Health
Center approach there must be other ways
models experiments patterns positive
things like group practice prepayment
Physicians assistance
outpatient care and discharge planning
and extended care facilities home health
and nurse coordinators
Beacon Street in Boston not quite the
same neighborhood as Columbia point but
exciting things are happening here as
well
the Harvard Community Health Center
another way of coping with some of the
stresses on our overtaxed Medical Care
System a prepaid multi-specialty group
practice the first in the nation
sponsored by a medical school the aim is
Quality Health Care for the whole
Community regardless of income the
method is prepayment membership paid
through monthly premiums like health
insurance or through government
assistance programs what are the
advantages of such a plan director of
the center Robert biblow explains the
best way to answer that question is to
describe what we have in this facility
what we have here are a variety of
Specialists who are able to confer and
be referred to by the Family Physicians
for a particular patient problems
the advantage is that they are Under One
Roof they need not be referred all over
the city
adequate diagnostic facilities here for
all patients
whether it be lab x-ray
electrocardiogram or whatnot so patients
can Avail themselves of a full range of
Services Under One Roof
there is also a common medical record
that is available to all Physicians they
all utilize the same medical record
and all this again simply means that
people can use this
program use this facility
um whenever they feel the need without
the fear that they're going to get
bombed with large physician bills
programs like the Harvard plan are now
being called Health maintenance
organizations Dr Robert Lord defines the
term a health maintenance organization
is an integrated system of providing
Comprehensive Health Services
it consists of an arrangement by a
contractor or an organization of some
kind which agrees to provide to an
enrolled population of people
Comprehensive Health Care on a prepaid
basis that is you pay in advance
the main meaning of an HMO it's great
strength is that it provides an economic
incentive to the providers of Health
Service to keep people healthy
and HMO will make more money literally
if the people it serves are kept healthy
while Group Health and HMO programs will
relieve much of the pressure on the
system leadership is called for from
hospitals as well
the new Denver General Hospital is
pointing the way
its director Dr Edward Dryden Lobby of
our new hospital you see it's a fairly
large and busy place
we've tried to set it up so it would be
appear to be an attractive place for
people to come into because it is their
Hospital
and also we wanted to think of it as
their health center as well
now when patients come in they come
directly here to the information desk
you'll notice from here they can be
directed immediately to any place they
need to go for example to the elevators
to the emergency entrance over there
to the admissions area over here and
they can even see here that there is a
small Nursery where they can leave their
children when they go to visit the
doctor
you might like to see the admissions
area where many people come most people
come in fact all right fine let's take a
look at it you'll see all these windows
here designed to make the weight as
short as possible we want this to be a
people's hospital and not set up for our
convenience
people are really sick they don't have
to stop here they go directly to the
emergency room
we've put a great deal of our energy
into making the ambulatory surfaces the
important thing we're set up to take
care of 400 000 visits a year to our
ambulatory services
this is the nursery that we spoke about
earlier where well children can come and
be cared for while they're waiting for
their brothers and sisters or their
mothers to see the doctor I think it's
very important to you pretty picture
would you believe this is the Pediatric
Clinic of a City Hospital
no it is very hard to believe that it's
so beautiful yes we tried to make it
that way to make it attractive
comfortable a nice place for people to
come
this is the waiting room of the
Pediatric Clinic
it's not as busy as many waiting rooms
that you may have seen in other clinics
many of our patients come here by
appointment in fact the majority but
it's still available for people to drop
in people from the community to come in
at any time they want
but you know we've got eight floors of
hospitals above us here
for inpatients and we've also considered
and we think it's every Hospital's
responsibility to consider early
discharge as well to plan for early
discharge of patients from the hospital
early discharge it means working to
reduce the time patients spend in
hospital rooms
at Denver's St Luke's Hospital public
health nurse Florence Fritz helps to
plan not only the early discharge of
patients but the type and quality of
care they will receive when they leave
we are in the hospital a full day and we
do have the time to answer questions to
review the cases that have been admitted
in the past 24 hours and to become
acquainted with the many patients and
their needs in the hospital setting Mrs
Fritz is a nurse coordinator in addition
to her work with the staff she often
counsels with the families of patients
concerning the problems involved in
Continuing Care such counseling is
particularly necessary when care of the
elderly is involved
in such cases Mrs Fritz will often
assist in getting a patient settled in
new surroundings such as this Extended
Care Facility part of a nursing home on
the outskirts of the city to the order
that Dr Khan has written for Mrs rathmar
are there orders for physical therapy
yes there are physical therapy orders
attached also occupational therapy
Apartments she is doing very well
ability of therapy continue until I'm
able to walk again this is why you are
in the extended care facility is for the
continuation of the Care many patients
are well enough to leave hospitals long
before they are released the less
expensive Extended Care Facility
provides for many of them a welcome
halfway house on their road to recovery
an Extended Care Facility offers
Physical Therapy occupational and speech
therapy and continuous skilled nursing
care patients are visited regularly by
their attending physicians doctors are
also on call when changes occur in their
patients condition an Extended Care
Facility provides more than custodial
care its goal is the full Rehabilitation
of the patient nurse coordinators are
able to perform many non-medical
functions relieving pressure on
Physicians overburdened by the
complexities of modern Medical Practice
other kinds of paramedic Personnel are
now actually assisting doctors in
medical work
assistant doctors
Joy it's already being done in some
places they 'll medics
[Music]
okay I've split it apart now
and cut right up the middle here
pull your hand up
how does it feel
s this young man has never been to
medical school but working closely with
a supervising physician he helps provide
care in many ways setting broken bones
suturing wounds assisting in diagnosis
and treatment
six weeks ago Mike carraher set Karen's
simple fracture
today he removes the cast and is
checking the x-rays with Dr Robert
Sherry his medical preceptor
Mike is a medics part of a new
experimental program in Seattle
Washington
this program and others like it are
making use of the valuable paramedical
skills of former GI Medical corpsman
there is a new Insignia in the world
today MX medics
Dr Sherry tells us about it
hi Dr Sherry what about the the training
of the medics where does it come from
well the Medics have diverse backgrounds
but most of the medics in the current in
the first year group were ex-green
Berets as was Medics carrier most of the
fellas had had independent Duty in
Vietnam he did not he had independent
Duty within the United States that is to
say he would go out on bivwax with the
troops and be responsible for whatever
he could handle that occurred while they
were away
now uh they then received three months
of formal training at the University and
then nine months of preceptorship making
a total of one year whether under the
tutelage of just one physician must they
function only in hospitals or in
Extended Care Facilities or can they
work elsewhere well I think that the
nice thing the Medics was evolved as a
general practice or Family Practice
concept and I think that the way that
they're used depends a lot on the man
that they're that they're practicing
with because there's a lot of difference
between my kind of practice in a small
town doctor in Eastern Washington say
you think Medics should be called
assistant doctor no I think Medics
should be called Medics they should be
seen as doctors helpers another kind of
Health Care personnel
Health Care delivery today has gone
beyond doctor and hospital to include
other kinds of medical personnel and
other locations for medical care
frequently the best and cheapest place
for treatment of a patient is in his own
home and it makes no difference if home
is in a ghetto a wealthy residential
neighborhood or a rural area working
under the home health program of the
Tennessee Department of Health nurse
Reba price and a speech therapist are
making one of their regular visits to
the home of James Robinson his partial
paralysis and speech impairment are the
results of a stroke Jimmy Robinson is a
good example of a patient that really
Home Care is the thing that he needs
he's with his family he's with people
who love him he's with he gets the
support that they can give him he's far
better off being in the home with home
care than he is in the hospital the
thing that many people do not realize
that even though the patient is on Home
Care he's under medical supervision The
Physician is still in attendance of the
patient and he has professional nursing
supervised by the by the public health
blue and we're moving well you're doing
well with those exercises yeah
yeah
bacon say bacon egg and bacon
eggs
but you know we said it would go real
slow we do real but a whole lot better
and say eggs eggs
good that's fine
[Music]
okay now
two three
two o'clock okay here
you know there's some pretty good things
happening out there after all but it
isn't organized it isn't systematized it
needs a plan something to tie it all
together well there's one thing that
ties it together right now like what
people people who care enough to try to
change things people are starting to get
involved all over the country and when
that happens things are bound to change
in Nashville Community concern about
health care is transformed into direct
community action using a time-honored
fundraising device Tennessee workers
hold a dance for help their goal a
prepaid Group Health Plan for their City
several trade unions have joined forces
with the area's Comprehensive Health
planning agency
our time we were talking about consumer
participation just exactly what form did
that take here the consumers have
organized and chartered in the state of
Tennessee the Tennessee Group Health
Foundation a non-profit
consumer-oriented organization which is
now Community it has a management labor
and community at large people it has
representation from the economic groups
it has representation from providers it
has representation fundamentally Harvard
that will assure that the consumer is
continuing in the decision-making
process of how Medical Care can be and
will be delivered for the purpose of
keeping people healthy it's very true we
work very closely
with Tom and his group on the Prepaid
Plan providing statistical data and
other information our Council has
supported it not only by in paper and in
writing but we've supported physically
in every other way we can we believe it
we believe that the people need a choice
and uh if you don't think so just add
some of them tonight
what happens when you get the bill
[Music]
well sometimes you sit down and think
about how you're gonna pay it if you
don't have hospitalization or you know
it's a wonderful plan program for the
people that really need it and have a
bunch of kids I feel that this is one
way if we can get a prepaid health
program in that this will benefit
everyone so this way we can budget our
money we know how much we have to spend
for medical care and it's not a
haphazard thing we've got to change the
health delivery system in this nation to
where we compensate doctors for keeping
people well
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but not the way I came in
this time I'm gonna do more than just
complain well we are getting there and
we'll need his help to make it work
along with the private medical sector
and the government still people will
need help to pay for it like a family
health insurance plan for the poor and
more help for the middle class they're
hurting too don't I know it
imagine Americans spend 70 billion
dollars a year on Health Care
it could buy a lot more care if we can
get this thing working
indeed but things are changing
it would seem to me they could change
even faster why not
yeah why not